d'accord
parce que les problèmes parce que les villageois
se sentent de ces plantations
et quand les éléphants
c'est tout ce quelque chose que tu es
depuis des mois
et qui me donnera de la nourriture pour mes
enfants pour voir comment les gens deviennent fous
et parfois tuent les éléphants
[Musique]
j'ai rencontré un
éléphant humain  le conflit au gabon
est un problème croissant et sérieux pour les
populations rurales les gens ne veulent pas
tuer tous les éléphants
mais ils veulent que
nous
fassions une sorte de division
et et et
euh nous
réagissons à cette demande euh aussi
vite que nous le pouvons  j'espère que nous irons encore
plus vite dans le futur
[Music]
do
you